trying to be a better friend to yourself
sounds like an odd idea initially
because we naturally imagine a friend as
someone else not as a part of our own
mind but there is value in the concept
because of the extent to which we know
how to treat our own friends with a
sympathy and imagination we seldom apply
to ourselves if a friend is in trouble
our first instinct is rarely to tell
them that they are fundamentally a
[ __ ] and a failure if a friend
complains that their partner isn't very
warm to them we don't tell them they're
getting what they deserve we try to
reassure them that they're essentially
likeable and that it's worth
investigating what might be done in
friendship we know instinctively how to
deploy strategies of wisdom and
consolation that we stubbornly refuse to
apply to ourselves there are some key
moves a good friend would typically make
which can provide a model for what we
should ideally be doing with ourselves
in our own heads firstly a good friend
likes you pretty much as you already are
any suggestion they make or ambition
they have about how you could change
builds on a background of acceptance
when they propose that you might try a
different tack it's not an ultimatum or
a threat then or saying that you have to
change or be abandoned the friend
insists we're good enough already but
they want to join forces with us to
solve a challenge they feel we would
properly benefit from overcoming without
being flattering good friends also
constantly keep in mind certain things
were getting right they don't think
anything wrong with the odd complemented
emphasis on our strengths it's quietly
galling how easily we can lose sight of
all our own good points when troubles
strike the friend doesn't fall into this
trap they can acknowledge the
difficulties while still holding onto a
memory of our virtues the good friend is
compassionate when we fail as we will
they are understanding and generous
around our mishaps our folly doesn't
exclude them from the circle of their
love the good friend definitely conveys
that to earth fail and screw-up is just
what we humans do we all emerge from
childhood with various biases in our
character which evolved to help us
with our necessarily imperfect parents
and these acquired habits of mind will
reliably let us down in adult life but
we're not to be blamed because we didn't
deliberately set out to be like this
we didn't realistically have a lot of
better options
we're indelibly required to make big
decisions before we ever really
understand what's at stake or how our
choices will play out with steering
blind in all our large moves around love
and work we opted for a move to a
different City but we can't possibly
know whether we're going to flourish
there we have to select a career path
when we're still young and we don't know
what our later needs will be in
long-term relationships we have to make
a commitment to another person before we
understand what it will be like to tie
our lives so deeply to there's the good
friend knows that failures are not in
fact rare they bring as a starting point
their own and humanity's vivid
experience of messing up interplay as
key points of reference they're
continually telling us that our specific
case might be unique but that the
general structure is common people don't
just sometimes fail everyone fails only
we don't know about it it's ironic yet
essentially hopeful that we usually know
quite well how to be a better friend to
near strangers than we know how to be to
ourselves the hopefulness lies in the
fact that we do actually already possess
the relevant skills of friendship it's
just we haven't as yet directed them to
the person who probably needs the most
namely of course ourselves
you